-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, there's a lot
going on in the news.
Today the FDA approved Pfizer
and Moderna booster shots.
Not only that,
a jury in Wisconsin
approved gunshots.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Yeah, today, Kyle Rittenhouse
was found not guilty
on all five counts
in the shooting
that killed two men
and injured one
during last year's
racial justice protests
in Kenosha, Wisconsin.
It just goes to show you can
do anything in this country,
as long as you're in the white.
[ Laughter and applause ]
On the --
On the right.
No, in the right.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's move on
to some lighter news.
It was a big day
for President Biden.
This morning,
he went to Walter Reed
for a routine physical
and a colonoscopy.
[ Laughter ]
I guess Biden's
infrastructure plan means all
of the tunnels
are getting worked on tonight.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
Yeah, but it wasn't
a typical colonoscopy.
-Really?!
-No.
Before the procedure,
Biden started talking
and the anesthesiologist
fell asleep.
-Oh.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
The anesthesiologist.
Colonoscopies can be
a little invasive.
That's why, before the
procedure, Biden was like --
-[Adele] ♪ Go easy ♪
♪ On me, baby ♪
[ Laughter ]
-But get this --
Well, after his procedure,
Biden took part
in the annual presidential
turkey pardoning
and last night
the two lucky turkeys stayed
in their own suite
at the Willard Hotel.
Here they are.
This is real.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Even weirder,
it was the fantasy suite.
[ Laughter ]
I heard that,
after their pardon,
most presidential turkeys go
to live the rest of their days
on a farm in Virginia
called Gobblers Rest.
[ Laughter ]
And, believe it or not,
all those pardoned turkeys
actually have
their own reality show.
Watch this.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Coming up on the next...
...Marshmallow throws down
the gantlet with Budge.
-[ Gobbling ]
-Carrot gets drunk
and belligerent at brunch.
-[ Gobbling ]
[Bleep]
-And Butterscotch throws
Caramel's prosthetic claw.
-[ Gobbling ]
♪♪
-Hosted by Nick Cannon.
-Ah, interesting.
What?!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some more news
from Washington --
today the House passed Biden's
nearly $2 trillion
Build Back Better Act.
And here's Speaker Nancy Pelosi
making the big announcement.
-On this vote, the yeas are 220,
the nays are 213.
The Build Back Better bill
is passed.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Hooting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Asked if that dancing
was awkward,
the yeas were unanimous.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Meanwhile,
Democrats actually planned
to vote on the bill
last night,
but House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy
gave the longest
continuous speech
in House history to stall it.
This is real.
He talked for eight
straight hours.
[ Audience ohs ]
Just listen to a little bit
of what he said. It's real.
-Picture America at a swim meet
after World War II.
I was in the sixth grade.
I turn on the TV.
I watch Jimmy Carter
have a sweater on
and tell me
to turn the heater down.
You ever eaten one
of these baby carrots?
They're just big carrots
they chop
and they charge you more
when you buy them.
Personally, I didn't think
I could go this long.
[ Laughter ]
-He did that for eight hours.
On the bright side,
when they heard
that he could talk
for eight hours straight,
Uber was like, "You're hired."
[ Laughter ]
Some business news --
I saw that Oprah
and Reese Witherspoon are
the newest investors in Spanx,
although,
from now until New Year's,
I think we're all
pretty invested in Spanx.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
McDonald's was just offering
a big promotion on Egg McMuffins
to celebrate the sandwich's
50th anniversary
and it was so popular
that their app crashed.
That's right, the McDonald's
app totally stopped working.
As a result, it was renamed
the McDonald's
ice cream machine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
everybody, come on.
-♪ I'm in the eye of the storm
where the pressure's on ♪
♪ MCs is dressed funny
like a leprechaun ♪
♪ I chop rappers up
like chicken Szechuan ♪
♪ Probably sell 'em off
like I'm at the auction ♪
♪ Ayo, my zodiac sign
read caution ♪
♪ Onstage, I make your seeds
to an orphan, ayo ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-What a show we have
for you tonight!
Her new 2021 holiday sweater
collection is available now
on nordstrom.com and berek.com.
Whoopi Goldberg is here
this evening!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Plus, she's a two-time
Latin Grammy winner
who is currently
on a sold-out tour.
Karol G is here!
[ Cheering and applause ]
And we have great music tonight
from Dry Cleaning, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Then, later in the show,
an all-new "Thank You Notes,"
so stay tuned for that.
That's tonight, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I also want to mention
tonight is Tariq's last show
for a few months
[ Audience awws ]
because -- This is good news.
Tariq, you're heading
into rehearsals
to star in a brand-new play
called "Black No More."
-Yes, yeah.
-Tariq.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Thank you.
-Now,
"'Black No More,' music
and lyrics by Tariq Trotter."
-Yeah.
When is the opening?
On January 11.
-Yeah, January 11,
you know, 2022.
-Yeah.
Opening night February 8th.
You can get tickets
at thenewgroup
-.org.
Yeah, .org. Thenewgroup.org.
-Yeah.
-Wait, so you start rehearsals
like next week?
-Monday.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-You've been working on this
for like five years, right?
-Yeah, five, six years, man.
-Six years.
You know, so much work goes
into this stuff. That's crazy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Congratulations. I couldn't
-Thank you.
-be more proud of you, buddy.
[ Cheering and applause ]
We're going to miss you.
What are we going to do?
-I don't know, man.
-What am I going to do?
I'm going to miss you, man.
-I'm going to miss
you guys, too, man.
It's bittersweet. Maybe,
I don't know, I'll Zoom in.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, yeah. We'll FaceTime in.
We'll put a screen there,
by the mic.
-Right.
-Yeah, and then,
we'll FaceTime in.
-I mean, we got a lot of cutouts
of me already, right?
[ Laughter ]
Just throw one of the
cutouts up, man.
-Yeah.
Either that,
or we can get Higgins
to start rapping.
-♪ Rrraya ♪
I do Shaggy, though.
-He can do Shaggy rapping.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-♪ Ya rrah rrrah rrah ♪
-♪ Rrrah rrah da ♪
♪ This is for Tariq,
he's a-gonna do a play ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ As to Tariq,
I'd like to say hurray ♪
♪ Hurray, Tariq! ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Shaggy.
-That's Shaggy.
The famous rapper.
-Thank you.
Yeah, of course, Shaggy.
Guys, we're in the middle
of the NFL season
and this Sunday night's game has
the Los Angeles Chargers
facing off against the
Pittsburgh Steelers.
-Whoo!
-Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
during the season.
I'll show you what I mean.
It's time
for "Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-Our first player is
from the Steelers. It's...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Medium, large, tire hole.
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"That's what's up."
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
He got an award for that.
-Yeah, he got an award.
What is that?
-It's very rare.
-Very rare.
-They rarely give that out.
-Wow.
-Next up from the Chargers is...
-Storm.
-He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
"Now, the weather
with Storm Norton."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Bit much.
Next up from the Steelers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter ]
[ Surfer voice ]
Almonds. Good choice.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Surfer voice ]
These are back in stock.
Nice!
-Oh, these are back in stock?
You got to be kidding me.
Right on.
-Sweet!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wait, I'm gonna go get some.
-I'm gonna get some
and I'm gonna try them
right in front of you.
[ Laughter ]
We'll eat almonds together.
[ Fresh laughter ]
Noice, noice, noice!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Freshly squeezed juice?
Noice!
Juice is noice!
[ Laughter ]
Can you agree with me on that,
juice is noice?
[ Laughter ]
Finally, from the Chargers is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are your "Superlatives."